أنا معجزة ، نعم ، أنا معجزة ، كثير
من الناس في المستشفى اتصلوا بي
بمعجزة طبية لمدة 18 يومًا على جهاز التنفس الصناعي
لمدة 30 يومًا تقريبًا في وحدة العناية المركزة ، سآخذ
المحقنة هنا ثلاث مرات أدخل أنبوبًا في
ثقب القصبة الهوائية ، وشفاء حلقه  لا يزال
يأكل من خلال أنبوب ، هذا هو
أنبوب معدتي في أسوأ حالاته ،
توقف قلبه تقريبًا عن الخفقان معجزة أنه على
قيد الحياة ، هل هناك نقطة
أدركت فيها أن هذا قد يكون هناك
نقطة يؤلمني فيها أن تأخذ
نفسًا واحدًا وقد فعلت ذلك بالفعل  في وقت
ما أريد فقط أن أموت ولكن بعد ذلك سمعت
صوتًا في رأسي يقول إنك
أناني لأنك اعتقد أنه
سيتخرج مار لابنة واحدة ويوم
ميلاد أخرى لديه زوجة
والدين وكنيسة وأصدقاء  الذي أحبه ،
كان لديه أيضًا فريق من الأطباء والممرضات
وأخصائيي الجهاز التنفسي الذين يعتنون
به ويسحبونه أنت تعلم طوال الوقت
الذي كان فيه هنا ، فأنت تعلم أنني لا أعرف
ما إذا كان مرضانا يمكنهم سماعنا أو حتى
سمعه ولكني اعتدت على ذلك  أقول له لا
تستسلم وأنا د  لا أعرف ما إذا كنت قد سمعت
ذلك وأود أن أعرف ما إذا
سمعني أقول ذلك له كيفن
يقول إنه يتذكر أنه لم يكن متأكدًا مما إذا
كان يتخيل ذلك ولكنه يتذكر ذلك
وممرضة تدعى بيث هي التي
صعد وأخبرني أنك تعلم أنني كنت
هناك في الليلة التي كادت أن تموت فيها وأنت
تعلم أنني لا أعرف شيئًا عن أن
كوفات 19 يبقي المرضى مثل كيفن في حالة
تخدير ومنفصل عن أحبائهم ،
يرتدي الطاقم الطبي أقنعة وأردية
يصعب معرفة من هو  كان بيث جيلسون في
الغرفة في أسوأ يوم يتأرجح فيه بدأ في
الانهيار ، وكان هذا عندما توقف قلبه تقريبًا
عن فعل ذلك ، لذلك كنت أعتني به في
ذلك اليوم وفي الغرفة معه بينما كان
كل هذا يحدث وعندما
رأيته  في اليوم الذي غادر فيه
المستشفى أخبرته أنني أخبرته
أنه على وشك الموت واعتقدت
أنه سيموت وأنا ممتن
جدًا لأنه لم يكن كيفين سوينك الآن
مصدر إلهام
للموظفين الذين أنقذوا  له كيف تتعامل
مع مرضى مثل كيفن
في التسول  بعد كل هذا
، لم يكن الأمر سهلاً بالتأكيد وقد
ترك الكثير منا في البكاء كثيرًا من الوقت ، لكنني
أعتقد حقًا أننا أصبحنا
معًا كدعم لبعضنا
البعض ورؤية الأشخاص يتحسنون
، لقد ساعدنا ذلك  حقيقة أن كيفن في
المنزل ويقوم بعمل أفضل بكثير ،
يساعدنا حقًا في معرفة أننا
نجعل هذا التأثير كبيرًا ، حيث
لم يكن كيفن يتأرجح بشكل نموذجي بطريقة أخرى في
50 عامًا ، ولا توجد حالات طبية أساسية ،
بخلاف ذلك ،
يعد لغزًا صحيًا آخر لـ kovat 19.  الأسباب التي لا تزال
غير مفهومة تمرض مميتًا بينما
يعرف الآخرون بالكاد أنهم مصابون به ، إنه
أمر محير للغاية بالنسبة لنا وأنت تعلم
أعتقد أن هناك أشخاصًا يبحثون
في سبب حدوث ذلك ، هل يمكن أن
يكون مرتبطًا بالوراثة هل يمكن أن يكون
مرتبطًا بالفيروس  العبء أو
كمية الفيروس التي تعرض لها الشخص
لشفاء كيفن غامضة مثل
مرضه كما أثبت والده أنه
إيجابي وقد لا يتعافى أفراد الأسرة الآخرون الذين
أصيبوا به أيضًا وبالكاد تأثروا به
فقط  لم أكن أعتقد أنني سأفهم
ذلك ، لم أكن أعتقد أنه كان هناك أي
احتمال أو أي شيء من هذا القبيل
عندما تم تصريفه ، نظمت كنيسته
موكبًا بالسيارة ، حيث سيشهد كيفن
التخرج وأعياد الميلاد وهو
يتطلع إلى الطعام الصلب.  جزء مزدوج
من كعك السلطعون في ماريلاند ، ما مدى حلاوة الحياة
حلوة جدًا ،
يتم تدريب هذا الكلب على اكتشاف
سرطان البروستاتا الذي قدمته مع
عينات البول ومكافأته عندما
تحدد النوع الصحيح الذي يستطيع هذا الكلب
التعرف على رائحة مرضى الملاريا
مهمتهم التالية  هنا
لتدريب الكلاب على شم الأشخاص المصابين
بـ kovat 19 بالطريقة التي سنقوم بها
من خلال الجمع باستخدام أقنعة الوجه
ونطلب من الأشخاص ارتداء
أقنعة الوجه هذه لبضع ساعات ثم
نجمعها بعناية  الشيء الآخر
الذي سنفعله هو جعل الناس
يرتدون جوارب نايلون تبدو غريبة بعض
الشيء لكننا نعلم من تجربتنا السابقة
أن هذه طريقة جيدة حقًا
لجمع الروائح من
الناس "  هذه طريقة سهلة للقيام بذلك إذا كان
التدريب ناجحًا ،
فمن المحتمل أن تكون إحدى أولى عمليات النشر الخاصة بهم هي
المطارات حيث يتم استخدام الكلاب بالفعل
لاكتشاف المخدرات وغيرها من المواد المهربة إذا
ساعدوا في إعادة فتح صناعة السفر
التي يمكن أن تكون بمثابة دفعة
للتجارة الدولية  لكن الحكومات في كل مكان
كانت تبحث عنه
قال إنني بحاجة إلى أن أقوم بمعاملة عدوانية إلى حد
ما ، هل لديك زوجة وأطفال ،
لذلك نحتاج إلى الاتصال بهم
وإخبارهم أننا بحاجة إلى أن نقول
لهم وداعًا لأن لديك حوالي 20
بالمائة  فرصة للنجاة من هذا
لا أستطيع حتى أن أتخيله ،
أعني أنه من الصعب أن أتحدث عن أصعب
جزء من كل شيء أتذكره هو
المكالمة الهاتفية مع زوجتي وأولادي ، أعني أن هذا كان
مروّعًا فقط
ما بدأ كنعش  انتهت الحمى
مع مايكل هربرت البالغ من العمر 49 عامًا في
وحدة العناية المركزة على جهاز التنفس الصناعي لمدة سبعة أيام
غير متأكد مما إذا كان سيرى عائلته مرة أخرى
لم أكن أعرف ما الذي سيحدث إذا
كنت سأوقظها في جميع
الأرقام  نسمع عن كورو
عدد المصابين بفيروس نافيروس الذين ماتوا للأسف
، لم نسمع الكثير عن
مجموعة أخرى من المرضى الذين
تعافوا ، وهناك أكثر من مليون
شخص تعافوا ، كثير من الناس في
حالة جيدة جدًا ، وقد يكون هناك بعض
الأفراد الذين سيقضون فترة طويلة  -تأثيرات
المدى لأن تقنية VAR تعتمد على
مدى شدة الفيروس ، كيف
تفعل ماذا يعني التعافي بالنسبة لك
عندما خرجت من المستشفى لأول مرة ،
كنت ضعيفًا جدًا وقد أخبرني
الأطباء بأخصائيي أمراض الرئة على
وجه الخصوص  أن رئتي ربما
تستغرق من أربعة إلى ثمانية أسابيع للشفاء
هو القلق من أنه قد يكون لديك
تأثير طويل المدى على رئتيك ، يمكنني
القول أنهما ليسا مئة بالمائة في الوقت
الحالي وأعتقد أنني لا يجب أن
أتوقع حدوث ذلك.  أخبروني أنه سيكون هناك بعض
الوقت بالنسبة لهم للعودة
مرة أخرى تمامًا مثل أي شخص آخر أعتقد أن
هناك الكثير من الأشياء المجهولة هنا لا
يزال هناك الكثير من الأشياء المجهولة وحتى
دراسة تعافي مرضى الفيروس التاجي.
med مثل الرفاهية في
الأيام الأولى لهذا الوباء اليوم
شديد جدًا ولكن الآن د.  يحاول Reynolds pon
Atari فك رموز هذه
المجهول من خلال إجراء دراسة مدتها ستة أشهر
لمرضى فيروس كورونا الذين
تعافوا ،
وهناك العديد من الحالات
والمشاركين الذين وصفوا هذا
التعب المستمر والشعور بالضيق والشعور بأنك لست على
ما يرام.
كانت العدوى
حتى رياضيين عدوانيين لم نكن نتوقع
أن شيئًا واحدًا يمكن أن
يساعد في التنبؤ بالآثار طويلة المدى هو
النظر إلى ما حدث أثناء
تفشي فيروس كورونا الأخرى ، ألق نظرة على
هذه الخطوط الليفية على
الرئتين التي تبدو وكأنها متناثرة.
يمكن أن يكون علامة مبكرة على
التليف الرئوي وهو نوع من
التندب في الرئتين
، وقد حددت الدراسات السابقة لفيروسات كورونا مثل السارس ومتلازمة الشرق الأوسط التنفسية المرضى الذين يعانون من
تليف طويل الأمد والآن
نشهد تقارير عن مرضى كوفات 19
لديهم نفس الخطوط الليفية على
يعد التصوير المقطعي المحوسب مثالًا آخر على ما
لا زلنا نتعلمه من العدوى إلى
التعافي  ما زلت غير متأكد تمامًا من
كيف سيؤثر هذا الفيروس علينا حقًا على المدى
الطويل ولكن بعد ستة أسابيع من اقتباس
ما تعرفه عن آلة التنفس
وفي عملية التعافي ، كيف حالك بعد
ستة أسابيع ، فأنا
أفضل حالًا عندما حصلت أخيرًا  لرؤيتهم
مرة أخرى في نهاية المطاف بمجرد خلع
جهاز التنفس الصناعي ، كنت مثل أفضل شيء
على الإطلاق كان
مصابًا بمرض ساكي الذي أزعجته وأخذت وسادة شعر
، كما علمت
الحاجي أنها معجزة هايجوم كنت قد حضرتها لعائلة فيني
حتى جهاز الاستنشاق
هذا ملف مغلق ليام
مرضنا الشائع فرانسيس سبين أبا-أبا-أبا
أرى أن مرض السلطة الماليزية
ملكة جمال مارو لم تقم بتركيبه جسديًا
استخدمه مع مرض كاواساكي أو
إيبارا والعدوى التي أريدها ظهرها أوه
هارلي لم تكن في المنزل لكنهم  لدينا
فيروس هنا ، حيث
سنراك نصفه هو G لديه المنار والملف الأعلى
لي فرايز وأنا بعد
امتحان دينمان وبارفاتي المزعوم مؤخرًا
هنا ، لقد سمحت لك لرجل ألاباما
جوليا وأبا فيل  أنا أزعم أن إدنا استهدفت
البلاستيك أو الشوكة في الجانب هنا
جانباً للتصدع ،
اسأل مثل Samuel T الثقيل هنا
فقط أصبح J في السياسة Natalie
دعنا نقول إنني أعني أنه مرض شديد أو
تجاوزهم حيوان حار كتلة مرهقة
خطر Manohar
سوف يقوم أصدقاء ماري بفحص LT فاتورة ثقيلة
ألثيا ملحوظًا كطفل صغير هاليت
لي ، لقد افترض أن رجلها الحمضي
مدرسًا ومعدنًا كما في ذلك مرض كاواساكي
المثالي في مارياني ، يشعر كل من المشرفين
بالتعفن على
بلادونا أولاً ، والدة جافا إل جيسون إذا
كنت هنا لأرى  هم معروضون للبيع كد
اسة لمخرج كوال تسلط الضوء على ال
ل في كاتدرائية مارتن لويس إبوكي في 19 أ
توبر ، رجل في فيلم أقل من وا
د في حمام السباحة في أشفق شيرين في
مي هاليك ولكن هاكونا ماتاتا لك
ي درست رائعة لا إلمو - حي
-  إعادة ملء ميا تعال واجلس معي
اللعين الذي كان لدينا في المنزل Illa the full
elven ale maracas fanciful million
netted and Barba F is G has lmond eye
and Marva and Robert 19 that my
allpathies out can b  هل
لم تكن يهود
ونصارة ما الذي أطعمه كاميل الجحيم CML
cytokine storm II Zeljko بالضبط
متلازمة الصدمة المرضية J Mattel Azamat Commissary
هذا هو Lotito أنا أبدأ
فجأة